-Our next guest is
a Grammy-nominated
singer/songwriter who is
out with a new single.
Performing "Good Person,"
give it up for Ingrid Andress.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Good person ♪
♪ How do you do it? ♪
♪ Do you just wake up with
a smile on your face? ♪
♪ Good person ♪
♪ What does it look like ♪
♪ Seeing the world
as a big happy place? ♪
♪ I'm trying to turn the page ♪
♪ Do you think I have
what it takes? ♪
♪ 'Cause I've cheated and lied
and made people cry ♪
♪ But I pray for the ones
that I love every night ♪
♪ And I've shattered some hearts
and my thoughts get dark ♪
♪ But I'd stop for a stranger
who's falling apart ♪
♪ I'm still learning ♪
♪ Good, good person ♪
♪ Do you ever lose it
when somebody steals ♪
♪ That one last parking spot ♪
♪ Good person ♪
♪ Do you ever say no? ♪
♪ Does the high road
get lonely? ♪
♪ Do you ever pull off? ♪
♪ 'Cause I've cheated and lied
and made people cry ♪
♪ But I pray for the ones
that I love every night ♪
♪ And I've shattered some hearts
and my thoughts get dark ♪
♪ But I'd stop for a stranger
who's falling apart ♪
♪ I'm still learning ♪
♪ Good, good person ♪
♪ Tell me how, tell me how ♪
♪ How to be a good,
good persoooooon ♪
♪♪
♪ Have you cheated and lied
or made people cry? ♪
♪ The right hand of God ♪
♪ Tell me what is it like ♪
♪ To throw all the stones behind
mirrors and smoke ♪
♪ Saying come to my show but you
won't let me go ♪
♪ Behind the curtain ♪
♪ Good, good person ♪
♪ Tell me how, tell me how ♪
♪ How to be
a good, good persoooooon ♪
a good, good person ♪
♪ Mmm-mmm ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]